hi it's Brianna from free code camp in
this video we are going to be talking
about what programmers do programmers
are also sometimes called coders
developers or software engineers and
what all of these people do they take
ideas and turn them into functional code
now it's not just the creating the code
it's also maintaining that code and all
the things having to do with keeping it
working and healthy talking about how a
computer looks at code specifically
JavaScript the computer looks at code
one line at a time and as you're writing
code you're going to notice these
numbers on the left hand side the
computer will literally go down line by
line making sense of what each line has
to say now what I've written here is not
actually relevant JavaScript there is no
that feed method but the point of this
is it does it looks at number one says
oh that's a comment I'm gonna ignore
that and move on number two fair Briana
equals new teacher it processes that and
then moves on everything is done
sequential II just straight down so if I
would try and write something up here
that reference something down here we
might have a problem you're going to
reference something make sure the
information that it needs is above it
because it does go down linearly now
that might be a little bit complicated
really all you need to know is it just
works down just like you would read a
book the most important thing to take
away from this video is programmers take
ideas and break them down into little
little tiny steps and write them in a
way that the computer can understand
them